ما هو المطلوب انا اسف طيب
ما هو المطلوب معرفه
وتقويه النفس
وتوجيه الاخرين كيماليه يا اخي يا اخي يا
اخي التفاؤل عباده
التفاؤل عباده ان يكون المبادره يا اخي
جزء جزء من قيمه الانسان والعادات ان
يتحرك هل مطلوب يقول والله ابقى في غرفتك
او انت احد زوايا بيتك ويبقى فيه هل هل
هذا المطلوب مني اعطيني منهج عملي خطوات
عمليه صحيح
يعني كلمه تعمل فيك اما قضيه نعطي خطوات
هذه ايش الاشكاليه
يريدك ان تحمله على اكتافك ويعتقد ان لديك
عصا موسى ويعطيك انك المغير يا اخي لو
اجتمع المسلمون على انسان لا يريد ان
يتحرك او يتغير والله لن يتغير همم هنا
الاشكاليه البعض يريدها سهله يريدها سهله
تريدون تريدين لقيانا المعالي رخيصه ولا
بد دون الشهد من ابر النحل ولولا المشقه
لساد الناس كلهم والجود يفكر هو الاقدام
قتال البعض عنده عنده لكنه قليل صبر
احداهن يوم من الايام كانت بين زوجها
ومشاكل كثيره فا اعطيت والله اعطيت خطوات
يوم واحد اعاده الى المستشار وقالت ما
تغير زوجها يعني الان تتكلم عن 15 سنه كان
بينها وبينهم مشاكل تريد ان تتغير فانا
اقول الاشكاليه في البعض هي ليست شوف يا
اخي هل مطلوب مني انني يوضح مشاكل انا يوم
لا يمكن كنت واشتكي شكوى يعني شكوى مؤلمه
وموجعه حتى ان الدموع تتساقط زين الام في
الظهر وتحدث هنا في اوروبا
يعني كان واحد لا انت
في اوروبا وتتكلم هم لا يعرفوا شيء عن
حياتي
هم لا يعرفون انا المطلوب انا كمتحدث انني
اقاسمكم شكواي او اقاسموه همي انا كما يا
اخي
انا ارتاح لما اسمع صوتك الدكتور خالد
وارتاح بكلام وعبارات وجميل
وفي لحظه من لحظات احس انه هذا العملاق
النائم في داخل يستيقظ نعم ولكن
لا اقدمه
ومع ذلك انا اقدمه فيها كثير من الخطوات
وفيها كثير من المنهجيات وفيها كثيره من
الاستراتيجيات وفيها كثير من الخطوات
العمليه انا كمان قلت لك البعض انا اقول
البعض قد تكون احيانا نقصر في جانب معين
وانا لا لا لا لا لا اثبت الكمال لكن في
بعض احيانا فسوه قصير اهي نفسه قصير ويريد
نتائج سريعه هنا هنا الاشكاليه لكن
الانسان عمو يا اخي قد افلح من زكاها لابد
يكون انسان يتحرك لو بدي يكون عنده حرص
والاهتمام والمسؤوليه هذه المسؤوليتك انت
لما انت المسؤول عن حالك الطرف الاخر الذي
اخترته ربما يقدم لك 10%15% وهي طريق وهي
رحله لا تتوقع تغيرا سريعا حاضر الدوره لا
ممكن تحرك فيه كلام ممكن تكون البدايه من
هذا المتحدث او من هذا المدرب او من هذا
الكتاب لكن لا الانسان ينشدون البشر عموما
ينشدون تغييرها لا لا لا لا لو انا خالد
اخي خالد الذي ياتي سريعا يده سريع
الذي يذهب عن دائما دائما
احدهم تكلم عن كتب التنميه البشريه انا لا
اشكاليه يا اخي انا ولا اقول كل فيها من
الاخطاء وفيها من المبالغهات وفيها من
المثاليات وفيه وفيها لكن
الخلاف بيني وبين من لديه مثل هذا الطرح
انه يؤمن هل قرات كل الكتب الان التعميم
الان يحتاج منك الى انت تاخذ عينه مناسبه
هل قرات كل الكتب طيب تعال انت انت الان
حذرته من كتب معينه من ماذا ما هي النقطه
ما هي الفكره التي حذرتها منه ولماذا اما
الكلام بشكل عمومي وهكذا الله يكفي كتب
كثيره نفعل الله بها وانا من خلال انك
نافع الله بها وغيرت اشخاص نقلتهم من حاله
الى حاله
والله يا خالد تغيرت حياتهم يعني
والله نعم الله علي لا تعد ولا تحزن لكن
الامر الذي يجعلني احلق في السماء انني
باحدهم يقول والله خالد انها كلمه او
مقاله لا القي لها حسابا انا متشبع من
هواء كنت اعتقد ان الناس يعني قد لا يتات
فاذ بها تؤثر تحرك حلقه تحرك على الاقل
تكون البذره الاولى زين وهذا امر الله
شكله شكل الحمد لله من نعم الله عليه ومن
نعم الله على وشوف اسال الله تعالى اسال
الله تعالى ان يخلص لي ولكن